Constantine tacos crossed the border
from Saint Petersburg to Finland two
days after Vladimir Putin's mobilization
order just before the country decided to
stop Russians with tourist visas from
entering we personally we never
supported this once our government is
doing anyways mobilization she was like
final
push for us ideally we want to go to
Netherlands
because that's where
People Like Us would feel comfortable
because of sanctions it's been difficult
for Russians to enter the European Union
hundreds of thousands have gone to
Georgia turkey or Kazakhstan
the German government offered Russians
who don't want to fight in Ukraine the
option of applying for Asylum if you
would have to join a war in which you
would have to commit crimes against
humanity and you don't want that and you
leave and you would be highly punished
then also that is a ground for
protection in Europe as a whole act not
only in Germany Europe is divided on how
to treat the many thousands of Russians
who are leaving the country now they run
the risk of being sent to Ukraine to
fight some countries like Germany and
France see their departure as an
opportunity to weaken Putin Finland and
the Baltic states say they're worried
about security Mark homankov left Russia
at the start of the war last February
and applied for asylum in Germany he
wants Europe against offering Russians
asylum in part because Germany is now
housing more than one million Ukrainian
refugees problem is that most of them
are still pro-russian people and what
they will do they will fight with
ukrainians they will fight with the
Europeans but those who come they need
to go through a very
very strict process
of distinguishing who you are
Constantine understands the concerns but
appeals to Europe to let Russians enter
I would think that if Europe would allow
this it will be a huge loss for Russia
and maybe for protein origin
and it will impact how soon this war
will end
trying to come up with a unified
response to the European commission set
claims for Asylum must be considered on
a case-by-case basis but called on
Airlines and Border agents to thoroughly
check all Russians wanting to travel to
Europe stop fast in Al Jazeera Berlin